i knew there was something dubious going
on here hey the things fans
we have a question for you have you ever
spent an entire disney movie trying to
figure out why one of the voice actors
just sounds so
familiar guess what you probably
recognize those voices from another
disney film
like how lady tremaine from cinderella
and maleficent from sleeping beauty
are played by the same actress in
today's video we're going over all the
disney characters
or should we say disney doppelgangers
you never realized we're voiced by the
same people
while princesses may be the shining
stars of disney
you have to admit the villains are the
ones who bring the movies to the next
level
it takes a unique actress to voice not
one but
two of the most iconic disney villains
of all time
eleanor oddly was not only the haunting
voice of maleficent in the original
sleeping beauty film
she was also used as a reference for the
animation
listen well all of you but her magical
career didn't stop there
she's also the chilling voice of
cinderella's stepmother lady tremaine
and i never go back on my word
alice in wonderland without the curious
voice of catherine beaumont
alice just wouldn't have had the same
mystical effect that she did in the
original 1951 film
i'm sorry but i don't quite understand
but
alice wasn't the only character
catherine spent her teen years voicing
there's a reason why you might have
found this voice from peter pan familiar
catherine also voiced wendy just two
years after alice
yes girls talk to her
we're not going to lie this next
voiceover doppelganger is
bizarre and we wouldn't be surprised if
no one has ever put these two characters
together
we all know how important side
characters are and the two roles
monica evans took on made the film's
heroes that much better
robin hood wouldn't be robin hood if he
didn't have his maid marian right
marrying my love will you marry me oh
darling i thought you'd never ask me
thankfully monica brought her along with
this the aristocats character
to life yep monica is made marian
and abigail the goose now think
goose it's safe to say that alan tudyk
is a disney legend
he's voiced not one not two but five
different characters in five different
disney films
his specialty pixar villains he voiced
weaselton
in zootopia it's weaselton duke
weaselton
and king candy in wreck-it ralph is that
a threat i smell
but his role in frozen is probably the
most shocking of them all
can we get a drum roll he's the voice
behind the duke of weaselton
wesselton duke of wesselton he also had
small parts in moana and aladdin
i can't take it anymore there are 101
dalmatians
but martha wentworth is not one of them
but
she is their nanny she had a way of
making her voice sound very
authoritative and strict
they are not mongrels but still caring
at the same time
that's why disney just couldn't pass her
up for this role in the sword in the
stone
she played madame mim how lovely
barbara luddy on the other hand was one
of the 101 dalmatians
she voiced rover i'm hungry mother
but did you ever think rover's voice
sounded familiar
we're only asking because she was the
actress behind three more pretty iconic
disney characters
she is the one the only lady from
lady and the [ __ ] you have a caller
and a license princess aurora's very own
godmother merryweather is also played by
barbara
oh it seems only yesterday we brought
her here
as well as kanga from winnie the pooh in
many different films
roo has a little surprise for you
we have yet another disney legend on our
hands
who would have thought that the actress
behind off with their heads
also known as the queen of hearts and
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo
cinderella's godmother were the same
salah
but voice actor verna felton also took
on two other roles that might
shock you she's the frazzled aunt sarah
from the lady in the [ __ ]
and the hot-headed winifred the elephant
from the jungle book
now you helped find him or i'm taking
over command
one thing is for sure verna's characters
get things
done it may be hard to imagine cogsworth
from beauty and the beast
as anything other than a helpful side
character but
his voice actor david ogden steyers
played some major disney villains
maybe he was trying to spice up his
acting roles but he's the voice behind
governor ratcliffe in pocahontas
it's a trick dr c and get this one
dr jamba jukiba from lilo and stitch
we got fired this morning phil harris
went beyond the bare necessities
when it came to his disney roles yes he
was in the jungle book
see what we did there he played
everyone's favorite bear blue
oh boy i've seen everything in these
woods
but he also lent his talents to films
like robin hood and the aristocats
in fact his character in robin hood was
also a bear
little john pretty hard to laugh hang in
there rob
he traded in the bear animation for an
aristocat
o'malley and i'm very proud of that
yeah next time you think criminal
mastermind
think tony j not in real life but the
disney characters he's voiced
are definitely questionable from sure
khan in the jungle book 2
all the way to monsieur diarch in beauty
and the beast
it's safe to say we'd never want to
cross anyone he brings to life
but it doesn't end there he also voices
claude frollo in the hunchback of notre
dame
chillz a monster
[Music]
frazzled scatterbrained trusty sidekick
you tell us what you think bill
thompson's disney roles can be described
as
they are super similar but different at
the same time
let's take a gander first we have mr
smee from peter pan can't believe it
and the white rabbit from alice in
wonderland
both roles are iconic and weirdly
similar
but then we have his role in lady and
the [ __ ] as jock
badly and uncle waldo in the aristocats
thoughts why you won't believe what they
tried to do
next up sterling holloway he was born
with a name
fit for hollywood all he needed were
some amazing roles to go with it
and he got them he took on the more
mysterious and mystifying characters
like kaw in the jungle book
and the cheshire cat from alice in
wonderland
but versatile should have been his
middle name because he also voices
flower in bambi
and rogue for it in the aristocats but
i'm a mouse
this voice doppelganger had us
absolutely shook
we're not over exaggerating either just
wait till you hear this
we all know the emperor's new groove had
the loyal and lovable pacha
he was played by john goodman if you
were a fan of pixar in the early 2000s
you
might already know where we're going
with this john goodman
is also behind the voice of everyone's
favorite monster
sully from monsters inc cue the mind
explosion
i can still hear her little voice
some people are known for villains
others for princesses
but james mcdonald he's known at disney
for all the voice acting he's done for
mice
sometimes even two different mice in the
same movie
he was the adorable jack and gus gus in
cinderella
and the dormouse in alice in wonderland
up
above the world oh also
he roared a lot basically whenever
disney needed an animal to roar
on screen they called in james he's even
the roar of maleficent's dragon form
[Music]
pat buttram had a respectable career
with disney as well
he played three different characters in
three different films
nottingham and robin hood chief in fox
and the hound
and napoleon in the aristocats hashtag
respect
listen wheels approaching
we definitely saved the best for last in
this video
if anyone is going down in disney's
books for voice acting history
it's going to be john ratzenberger he's
been
in every single pixar movie every single
one
his most notable roles are ham and toy
story
all right nobody look till i get my cork
back in yeti and monsters inc
hey why can't they call me the adorable
snowman and the underminer in the
incredibles
but you can also catch him in nemo wally
up cars brave inside out finding dory
and onward after hearing all these
voices side by side
it's hard to believe we've gone all
these years without putting the puzzle
pieces together
what voice reveal absolutely had you
shook
let us know in the comment section below
make sure to hit that subscribe button
for more mind-bending videos like this
one
thanks for watching